PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I want us to
work on the following problem.
So we're going to assume little
f is a continuous function.
And if we know that the integral
from 0 to x of f of t dt
is equal to x
squared sine pi x, I
want us to find little f of 2.
So I'm going to give
you a little while
to work on the problem.
When you're ready, come
back and we'll take a look
at how I do the problem.
Welcome back.
So again, we're
working on a problem
where we know that f is
a continuous function.
We know that the integral
from 0 to x of f of t dt
is equal to a certain function.
And we want to find f of 2.
So what we're going
to use, because we
know little f is
continuous, we can actually
use the fundamental
theorem of calculus.
And we know that d/dx
of this whole expression
here is actually little f of x.
So let's just remind us--
I'll write it down formally.
FTC implies that d/dx, the
interval from 0 to x f of t dt
is equal to f of x.
Right?
We know that.
So, we know that d/dx
of the right-hand side
and d/dx of the left-hand
side are the same.
And so we know that if we take
d/dx of the right-hand side,
we'll get little f of x.
Because d/dx of the left-hand
side of this equation
is little f of x.
So d/dx of the right-hand
side is also little f of x.
So now what we
have to do is apply
what we know about taking
derivatives to find little
f of x.
Then once we find
little f of x we
can evaluate it at f equal 2,
at 2-- sorry-- at x equal 2.
Sorry about that.
So let's come over to the
right part of the board
and we'll find d/dx
of this function here.
So what do we have to use?
We have to use the
product rule and then
we'll have to use a little chain
rule, a really simple chain
rule in the second term.
I'm going to write
it down below,
so we have some room here.
So the first term,
we get 2x sine pi*x.
The second term
we get x squared.
Derivative of sine is cosine.
pi*x.
And then we have
to pull out a pi.
Which I'll just put, well I'll
put it here for the moment.
The pi comes from taking
the derivative of pi*x.
And now all we need, this
is then f of x, right?
So I just will remind
us this is f of x.
Let me put it right
here, a little f of x.
So if I want to find f
of 2, all I have to do
is evaluate this at x equal 2.
So f of 2 is going to
equal-- 2 times 2 is 4--
sine 2*pi plus 4-- I'll
bring the pi in front--
4*pi cosine 2*pi.
So what do I get?
Sine 2*pi is 0.
Cosine 2*pi is 1.
So ultimately, I just get 4*pi.
So, hopefully you were
able to solve this problem
and get the same answer.
Now let me remind you,
one more time what we did.
Let's come over here.
We started with a function
that we knew was continuous.
We knew the integral from
0 to x of that function
was equal to a
certain function of x.
And we wanted to evaluate
this function at a certain,
at a certain point.
So what we exploited was
the fundamental theorem
of calculus.
And the fundamental
theorem of calculus
tells us that d/dx of the
left-hand side is f of x.
And so that we can take
d/dx of the right-hand side
and figure out what f of x is.
And then we just evaluate.
So I think I'll stop there.